hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to subnautica now we've
got a mission ahead of us we have to go
and get the materials for the hatching
enzymes for these eggs now some people
in the comments said that they were in
this area but I've actually traversed
this area and there doesn't seem to be
anything besides the creatures that are
here and some small bits of fauna and
flora like the things that allow me to
have oxygen now the the required
materials are as follows as such
Gabe's feather sea crown membrane tree
Rouge cradle and I need to bring them
all back here in crap or I need to craft
them in my own little doodad or over
there but there doesn't seem to be
anything here unless you're something no
you're not there's a hole okay blueish
that's not important that's not what
we're looking for right here
there's also various water you well
you're just a platform you're up you're
a slab of concrete everyone let it be
known that markiplier was enticed by a
slab of concrete
anyway so I've glanced around and there
really isn't anything else here that is
gathering I think what I think is a loop
article bruster so I care about that oh
yeah yeah y'all get solved it rec hall
i'm lizzing yeah to what I think is like
this is intended as like an all big old
dude Dadar thing where you got to go
back and do a whole bunch of [ __ ]
and I may be mistaken and I may be a
horrible idiot here but then again
that's what I've been the whole time
this game so it's not going to be any
different but what I'm going to do is
I'm going to try to go back up there I
don't know if I'm actually going to make
it because the benefit being there AR is
there is poor towels ah I think I'm
gonna make it I got the upgraded jet so
I better be able to make this if I don't
make this oh come on crap right now oh
[ __ ] if it's ooh
hey okay cool so there are portals that
lead to all the other areas in this
entire little please because what I got
to do now is I got to go out to the
various different biomes because I
haven't even been able to find out where
these seeds are from the wiki so it's
kind of going to be an exploration thing
but I'm pretty sure I'm pretty sure that
each one of these here
fools they point me in the right
direction to be able to get everything
that I need and I haven't activated them
so I gotta go activate some so I gotta
kind of be like yes wherever it pops me
it's gonna pop me like I do a lot of
navigation my hand here and if I do that
then I'll be happy
[ __ ] right you carry on I'm gonna shove
them on green thing inside you that
sounds sexual but it's not now I'd go
inside of this big old green butthole ah
here I'm gonna be in a cave or I'm gonna
be out in the middle of nowhere where
was this
oh did nilly whoa where am I
Oh what I didn't even know you were here
don't you mess with me bro I'm not in
the mood to be messed with
in fact I'm never in the mood to be
messed with yeah I didn't even know this
one was here ah okay you don't like me
ye umm pity there are four portals four
portals for seeds makes and convenient
game mechanics let me just go through
this one because I got to remember and
then I'm going to drink some piss and
then we're going to be good to go
because the big problem is that my
Cyclops is down super deep down there so
other either I have to bring it back up
to the surface or I can bring it back up
to this point but I think that must be
wood okay alright night light out then
but that one must be what it is when it
says mom am moving the am brain tree
that must be the big-ass piece of [ __ ]
that was up over here and then I can use
the portals now because they're all
activated then I should be able to go
where I need to go but that could answer
my question so what I'm going to do is
I'm going to pack up my bags in my good
old my good old Cyclops over there and
then I'm gonna go through the valley of
death again and the fire and the flames
in the dubstep to be able to get back to
where I can get like at least around
because now that I got the portals all I
gotta do is I gotta get my Cyclops the
[ __ ] outta here because I don't want
there to be down there anymore but also
that means they can bring my Cyclops
where my C Mon I gave your bubble better
get off it myself enjoy
the reason I'm not just immediately
going out and I oh hi buddy
the reason I'm not immediately going out
and just going to get those things each
one at a time through all the portals is
because there are other things in this
update that I want to see there is a
special surprise that I'm going to head
for as soon as I can get back to the
surface all right here we go
seems clear I can't believe I can't
believe bubble butt or ms:i big box
Barry I can't believe big bucks Barry
haha oh God I still got a hitchhiker
with me but you know song is on oh okay
whatever could Adly do I'm running away
now it's deadly dude who's about to hit
me someone's not too happy about where I
am but now comes the arduous journey of
getting a pop out of hair oh why are you
coming over here why are you coming over
here why are you coming over here why I
am silent I say as I'm screaming oh [ __ ]
okay we're fine bubble Oh yuck oh that
guy got blasted into either holy [ __ ]
[ __ ] why am i following you go away
please
whoa [ __ ] me okay would never see a
porno hi okay hi welcome
what
markiplier you know big bits baby by
definition you know it's a good life
that I live alive so don't don't do that
again I already answered your call so oh
there she blows oh she's so beautiful so
beautiful come to me come to me
I need a seed from you can you help me
can i seduce you can I can you just
start producing seed so if there ever
were a membrane see seed I would think
that it would be from this yard tree
that looks membranous I mean this thing
looks super important so you'd think you
would think you'd think that this would
be uh something to do with that yeah ha
hee gotcha
got him great well I don't know man it
was a good thought but I guess not
all right if I'm wrong about this make
me come back to this like just tell me
in the comments like cuz I didn't see
anything but then again maybe I didn't
look hard but either way onward its
glory that is still my ass one seems to
be riding underneath me I probably got
him grinding under my tires here yeah
I'm going this way back because I need
to get closer to my base and actually
get my C Mon
oh I didn't even think that he might
still be here
Oh I had forgotten about you
ah you're going to be a problem for me
oh no oh no oh yeah you you are not
oh no no [ __ ] dare you looking right
at me don't do it don't do the pain hey
you hippie hippie yo Joe what can you
got me pinned gonna be pinned oh my god
oh my god oh my god oh my god oh my god
I can't get out oh my god let me out let
me out stop pinning me
okay I'm out of here [ __ ] your urgency
speed [ __ ] that [ __ ] gg gg gg gg
oh the tights quiz the tightest squares
going at at full speed which is always
smart and we're free no we're not free
oh hey ray good job me I did it okay
where's my [ __ ] where's all my Garbo
where's my landmarks why okay hello
there's all my landmarks where's my C
Mon there it is there's much stuff over
there why am I not getting a I'm not
getting a beacon for literally Oh bubble
bot you're out of your dock are you out
of your dock are you out of your hickory
dickory dock Oh lion stun - nothing okay
there we go welcome yay
and amazingly this place still has power
okay so we got through oh yes
so we get the pressure come dinner I'm
going to take that because that can
survive up to 900 anyway and I shouldn't
need to actually go 900 anymore and then
bah bah bah
oh oh but oh go anyway we're gonna put
that MERGA pressure compensator under
there
we don't need this one but I'll just
leave it in there because I feel like oh
and Pablo by bubble butt so cute how can
I forget you bubble butt oh my god
you're not charged up well get in your
dock all right you black okay it wasn't
even charging why wasn't it charging it
was taking all the power what are you
what are you taking power from I'll get
out of here get out here all right
whatever
that's more like it oh you're so fast I
missed you I missed you so much
[Music]
all right so all that aside I know that
was a long way to get to a not a lot a
whole lot of something but there was an
objective out here and the last thing
I'm going to do in this episode is I'm
going to find the lost Life pod Life pod
7 is over somewhere here I don't really
remember where but somewhere over here
exists a life pod with a very very
special item inside so I'm going to
follow these until I make my way to the
crag fields where it is now I don't know
the specific location but I'm just going
to take a little Joyride with bumble bud
here and we're gonna have a fun time
anyway sorry excuse you I gotta keep an
eye out I got to keep an eye out oh
never mind it's right there
hell yeah you know I'm away by H so in
this in this lovely little Life pod here
is a very special surprise
there's a toy car number one there's a
sample that's but also me an unusual
doll it's right here and then I have it
forever or at least I can make it right
that's what it is oh there it is
hope hole plates an unusual dog glass
and titanium yeah that sounds about
right
someone's not happy about that Vanden
BAU gray cap okay all right I got a
whole bunch of [ __ ] here cool let me
get back in my boat and then get out of
here
bumble but we are rowdy here we got
exactly what we needed
do little little you lift it did it do
that it a turd ah [ __ ] so I'm not going
to Park you in there because apparently
you dream too much power but I am going
to pop in here I'm going to find me some
glass I don't know if I have any glass
I'm going to go oh I know what I can do
to get glass I can disassemble these
useless things here I don't know why I
still have them here but yeah get the
quartz out of that and if I get to
quartz oh I already got two quarts
nevermind then I guess they'll just
selvedge another one of these that one
leaves there for posterity when they
make the glass right there
LVT is it like something in here that I
can make miscellanies ball oh my oh my
god he moved that's not natural but okay
I'm just going to have him standing in
the middle of this hallway because it's
easily the only place appropriate for
him oh God
oh hey hey it's me I can scan him again
oh [ __ ] the scan demand oblivion what
the [ __ ] my glass went away oh [ __ ] mm
oh look at him look at him look at him
let me deconstruct and see if it
actually gives me the right thing okay
it did let me see if I can put him up on
like it this ah I wish I could put him
up there in this work oh it can and
yeah yeah yeah yeah look at me yeah oh
that's so cool
oh that's so cool anyway so that's where
I'm gonna end this episode in the next
episode I have the objective of finding
these seeds so if you know where they
are and you don't you're not gooping me
let me know down in the comments below I
know the portals probably lead to them
so I need that as a basis but either way
thank you all so much for watching thank
you developers for putting this adorable
doll in the game and as always I will
see you in the next video bye-bye
[Music]